there exist three devil fruit categories
in the world of one piece with each one
granting users Incredible strength and
abilities however out of these three the
loia devil fruits are said to be the
rarest allowing users to transform their
bodies into natural elements making them
immune to all attacks today we'll be
explaining and ranking all 17 loia users
starting with one of the strongest
characters in the entire show and a
certain record holder Admiral kizaru
kizaru is the user of the pika pika no
me a lokia devil fruit that allows him
to transform into light the best thing
this fruit lets him do is travel at the
speed of light which pretty much makes
him the flash of the one piece Universe
since kizu has had this fruit for
several decades he's developed many
interesting ways of using his light
abilities in combat he usually fights by
kicking his enemies at light speed but
can also shoot powerful laser beams from
his fingers or play it dirty by creating
a super bright flash that blinds
everyone around him but even he's not
crazy enough to go kicking against a
swordsman that's why when he fought the
dark King Ry he created a sword of pure
light to match him although kado comes
off as a goof most of the time he's very
serious about his Marine duties and
always prioritizes his missions for
example after failing to capture RA in
the straw hats kizu got mad going on a
rampage and imprisoning 500 pirates in a
single day which is more than any other
Marine so how does kizu compare to some
of the strongest characters in the story
well he doesn't disappoint just recently
he went head-to-head with the new
emperor of the sea Luffy while he didn't
exactly win this fight and got paralyzed
by Luffy's punch he showed that he's
perfectly capable of holding his own
against an emperor which earned him a
spot in the a tier some of you may think
that he deserves to be an S tier but
that place is reserved only for absolute
monsters as you'll soon see but not
every loia element is as cool as light
is and this next character was so
unfortunate to get the worst loia
element in the series kadu ate the suzu
suu Nomi a loia type devil fruit that
allows him to turn into soot which is
pretty much just burned dust however he
never turns into just regular soot and
instead turns into crows made out of
soot for example he uses these crows aot
lot to fly and carry his allies but also
for simpler things like bringing
newspapers this is actually how we get
introduced to his ability all the way
back in chapter 593 despite creating
crows katu's name literally translates
to Crow and he's also dressed as one man
this guy has one unhealthy Obsession
anyway the only real fight katasu
participated in was when the
Revolutionary Army attacked Maring joah
to free Kuma here katasu confidently
attacked Admiral fujit TOA all by
himself proving just how confident he is
in his abilities although this is pretty
impressive due to very limited
information about his General combat
abilities I'll have to put him in C tier
for now hunting Queen hunting Queen ate
the Toto Toto noi a fruit that lets her
turn into and control liquid
specifically syrupy liquid from what
we've seen she usually uses her
abilities to travel through pipes and
shoot beams of syrup honestly this route
has the potential to be really strong
but sadly honey Queen just isn't that
skilled with it I mean she literally
lost the battle by getting caught in a
jar her Bounty is also the lowest out of
all LAN users being only 7, 800,000
berries if you're scratching your head
thinking when did she appear in the show
I don't remember her at all well she
didn't she's one of the main antagonists
in the one piece movie too anyway I
think we can all agree that honey Queen
deserves to be our first f-tier loia
user let's go back to Canon characters
now and cover a character who literally
has the ability to instantly defeat
anyone no matter how strong they are
Caesar Clown ate the GSU gasu no me and
while it obviously allows him to
transform into gas he can also fuse with
and spread any gas he creates on top of
that gosomi is one of the few loia
fruits that allow the user to fly freely
there were only two more loia fruits
like this but more on that later anyway
for an average human this fruit would be
pretty much useless as it requires vast
knowledge about chemistry and gases in
order to be used properly however if
used by a genius like Caesar this fruit
can be unstoppable for example using his
scientific knowledge Caesar can surround
himself with flammable gas and then
ignite it to make an explosion but the
deadliest ability this fruit grants to
Caesar is the ability to remove all
oxygen around him making his enemies
unable to breathe this pretty much
allows Caesar to defeat enemies much
stronger than himself without any effort
as long as he can get close to them
despite his incredible fruit Caesar is
primarily a scientist not a fighter and
therefore I think D tier is a Fitting
Place for him Admiral greenbull during
the time skip greenbull was introduced
as one of the new Admirals to fill one
of the two empty spots as with the
majority of the Admirals he has a loia
type devil fruit called Mo mod no meat
which lets him become in controll trees
flowers and grass literally the whole
Forest being the forest man is
definitely a really weird ability and it
has its pros and cons for example green
bold never has to eat because he can
photosynthesize like plants but this
also means he can burn very easily due
to him being made out of wood and leaves
for traveling purposes greenbull can
attach a spinning flower to his back
that allows him to fly but how does he
utilize this fruit in combat well when
fighting weaker enemies green bow mostly
commands Ritz to attack and then drain
them of all water but against stronger
foes he transforms into a huge tree man
which is pretty creative now we never
got to see the full extent of green B's
Powers as Shanks quickly interrupted the
fight and very gently asked the Admiral
to go home the only other battle
greenbull took a part in was when the
Revolutionary Army attacked Mary joah
and we already know that didn't go well
for the Admirals many fans are
disappointed with green B's strength so
far but I think he just didn't have his
time to shine yet for now A B tier seems
right for him however this next
character will never get her time to
shine as her story ended in the most
unlucky way possible you see Monae was
first introduced to Caesar's secretary
but later on we found out she was
actually a member of the donot Pirates
sent to monitor in she ate the Yuki Yuki
no me a loia type devil fruit that
allows her to control and turn into snow
she mostly uses this snow to capture her
opponents but can also fight by
hardening her wings making them as hard
as blades aside from turning herself
into snow Monae can also transform into
a snow beast when she gets angry the
interesting thing about her is that her
wings aren't the result of her devil
fruit and aren't made of snow those are
actual Wings given to her by law during
the punk Hazard Arc Monae was able to
easily defeat tashigi using her powers
but was completely helpless against zodo
whose presence was enough to freeze her
in place pretty ironic considering that
she's made out of snow although zodo
decided to spare her she didn't live for
very long after that because Caesar
accidentally stabbed her heart instead
of smokers which has got to be the
unluckiest way to die even though Monae
had a good Mastery of her fruit I can't
place her any higher than etier as some
of the other characters we cover soon
are tens or even hundreds of times
stronger than her and one of those
characters is the fleet Admiral sakazuki
sakazuki ate the magum magu no me which
allows him to turn his body into magma
this devil fruit easily takes the spot
as the strongest offensive devil fruit
in the series as its raw power is
unmatched even just a touch from
sakazuki can leave you with a hole in
your body I sure hope this doesn't
happen to anyone important akina was the
only Admiral who fought with Whitebeard
one-on-one for an extended period of
time and even gave him some ser serious
injuries it's also important to mention
that even after getting hit by some of
whitebeard's strongest attacks he still
managed to stand up and continue
fighting proving that his defense is as
good as his offense sakazuki is by far
the most serious out of everyone when it
comes to his Marine duties I mean the
guy literally destroyed the entire ship
full of innocent people just because he
thought that some Traders were on it
leaving other Marines in shock although
sakazuki attitude usually makes him
hated in feared he has one person in the
Marines he can call a friend and that's
kizaru they joined the Marines at the
exact same time and he's the only person
of kind who seems to have genuine
conversations with ever since the time
skip we didn't see much of sakazuki due
to him becoming the fleet Admiral which
means he rarely fights and just sits in
his office all day and screams at people
the only time he got out of his chair
was when he went to capture Kuba on Mary
joah but we didn't see much in terms of
his abilities during that fight still
sakazuki is currently the strongest
marine officer in the show and he's
going to be a menace when he finally
fights for real due to this I think
sakazuki is worthy of being the first s
tier on the list but he might not even
be the strongest character cover today
which just goes to show you how insane
loia users are however having one of the
strongest devil fruits like sakazuki
doesn't mean you'll be as strong as him
which we saw in nl's case using the Goro
goromi a loia type devil fruit that
allows him to turn into lightning NL
easily took over the entirety of Skype
and became the self-proclaimed God most
of anel's attacks revolve around
attacking his opponents with powerful
bolts of lightning he can freely control
the power output he unleashes up to a
maximum of 200 million volts he was also
one of the few people in the early one
piece capable of using observation
hockey for example he could hear people
talking from a really long distance and
if anyone said anything bad about him he
could just Smite them down with a
lightning strike all the way from his
home nl's ultimate technique is using
200 million bolts to transform himself
into an electron giant called amaru
which Bears a striking resemblance to
the Thunder God Rene but despite all
these incredible Powers enel had one
huge weakness he relied on his devil
fruit too much this is why when he found
out Luffy's body was immune to lightning
he didn't know what to do and was
quickly defeated although this devil
fruit is insanely powerful and probably
comparable to Admiral's devil fruits in
terms of strength considering anel's
flaws and lack of experience I can't put
him any higher than catier there's still
nine incredible loia users left to cover
and let's continue with sir crocodile
crocodile was the first person to
completely beat Luffy in a fight with
Luffy not being able to hit him once due
to his ability to turn into sand granted
by the devil fruit he ate the sunna sua
know me crocodile uses this fruit in
combat by creating a huge Sandstorm or
summoning sand spikes from the flooor
aside from this the sunos suo noi allows
him to Drain Liquid from anything he
touches now you may think that's not so
special since green bull can do it too
but crocodile did it before it was cool
a whopping 1,3 episodes before him
although this fruit is pretty strong it
has one devastating weakness water you
see as soon as crocodile comes into
contact with water his sand hardens
making him unable to dodge attacks which
allowed Luffy to eventually defeat him
during alabasta but losing to Luffy this
early on doesn't mean the crocodile is
weak which he showed during the summit
War when he briefly engaged in fights
with mihawk doflamingo and even managed
to catch a kuu off guard after the time
skip crocodile became one of the leaders
of an emperor crew the cross Guild and
earned himself a bounty of almost 2
billion berries it's only a matter of
time before we see him fighting again
and I think we'll all be surprised by
just how strong he's become which makes
B tier a Fitting Place for him Simon one
of the weirdest devil fruits in the
series absolutely has to be Simon's posa
pasonomi this true lets him turn into
paper which is pretty odd for loia power
since the paper is really light Simon is
the second character on this list who
can freely fly Simon was a pretty strong
guy with many people saying that his
strength was on par with a warlord of
the sea he usually fights by launching a
bunch of papers at his enemies but these
are not your usual papers you see
depending on the symbol he puts on the
paper it could be able to poison
electrocute or even blow up his enemies
it's likely that none of you heard of
Simon and that's completely
understandable since he only appears in
the one piece game for the Game Boy
Advance forus D Ace Ace was the son of
the pirate king Goldie Roger and was in
possession of metam metan noi a loia
type devil fruit which allows him to
control fire during fights Ace would
shoot the fire from his fingers like
pistols creating fire waves or even big
Fireballs however his signature attack
was transforming his fist into fire
which earned him the nickname fire Fist
Ace although Ace was a pre-time skip
character his powers were no joke for
example on alabasta he matched smoker
who at the time seemed unbeatable and
also destroyed the Baro Works Fleet a
single attack later in the story we also
found out that he fought against yam on
equal footing which just proves how
powerful he was so yeah Ace was pretty
strong but his rational thinking could
use some work he wanted to catch his
former crewmate Blackbeard and when he
finally found him he decided to attack
him completely alone which obviously
wasn't the smartest thing to do he was
then almost freed during the war but
just had to turn back when ainu started
insulting his captain and let's just say
that magma turned out to be much hotter
than fire never nevertheless Ace was
certainly a powerful pirate and welld
deserving of catier up next is the first
ever loia user we've seen in the show
the vice admiral smoker smoker ate the
moku moku Nomi a devil fruit which lets
him turn into well you'd never guess it
smoke due to Smoke's natural properties
he's another one of those loia users
able to fly his usual way of catching
Pirates is surrounding them with Den
smoke trapping them most of his other
attacks also revolve around dense smoke
like shooting a big cloud or creating a
smoke dragon that pursues his enemies
however the most ridic ridiculous way
smoker uses the power of this fruit is
to power his Bower bike now that I
mentioned it what the heck even happened
with this thing anyway ever since smoker
first saw Luffy in L toown he's become
kind of obsessed chasing Luffy into the
grand line which created this cool
rivalry between them although a lot of
people absolutely love smoker as a
character the fact is ever since he
entered the new world he's only been
losing fight after fight this is why
we'll have to place him in the D tier
for now only five more characters are
left and let's continue with one of the
strongest active Pirates the Titanic
Commander Kuan kuzan's devil fruit the
hiahia noi is pretty much an upgraded
version of Monet's Yuki Yuki noi since
it allows him to literally control the
cold itself rather than just snow
throughout the show we've seen Kuan
utilize the power of this fruit in many
unique ways like freezing his enemies
creating weapons out of ice and even
enhancing his fists with ice for
additional power another interesting
thing is that Kuan can also replace his
body parts with ice this was shown when
he lost a leg in a battle against Ayu
and replaced it with a fake one made out
of ice while this fruit does not allow
kuzan to fly he has his own much cooler
way of traveling he literally freezes a
big chunk of the ocean then Rises
bicycle over it on top of all these
incredible abilities kuan's physical
strength is also monstrous due to the
battleship punching training he did with
gar during the time skip Kuan decided to
leave the Marines and join the
Blackbeard Pirates as one of the 10
Titanic commanders this decision
eventually led him to fight against his
former Mentor the hero of the Marines
GARP who he managed to defeat with some
help from his crew mates it's evident
that Kuan is a top tier fighter but
since he lost to sakazuki I'll have to
place him in the a tier gasparde
gasparde is another really weird loia
user his fruit is called the am am noi
and it allows him to become and control
the element of candy syrup Gaspar
usually fights by growing candy spikes
out of his body similar to miss double
fingers togy toi noi it's obvious that
he hasn't mastered his loia abilities
yet shown by how surprise attacks still
managed to hurt him but even if we put
that aside gaspari has another huge
weakness candy syrups natural enemy
flower you see touching flower makes
gasparde lose his stickiness making him
vulnerable to non- hockey attacks
although gasparde was the main
antagonist of One Piece fourth movie he
doesn't appear to be strong at all as
Luffy pretty much beat him up in like 2
minutes considering this it's only
natural we place him at the bottom of
the tier list Caribou since Caribou
reached salv with a bounty of 210
million berries he was considered one of
the supernovas of the new generation
just like Luffy was a couple of years
ago he ate the Numa Numa noi a loia type
devil fruit that allows him to become a
swamp Caribou utilizes this fruit in
fights by Drowning people inside his
swamp which acts similarly to quicksand
but sometimes he even shoots a machine
gun that he keeps in himself yeah it
sounds a bit weird but he can store
whatever he wants inside his swamp
weapons people you name it we've only
seen caribou's abilities a couple of
times and there's a good reason for that
the man has been through a lot he was
first imprison on the straw hat ship
then beaten up by Jim Bay and left at
the Marine base after he escaped he was
beaten up again by XR and sent to the
prison in wano now he finds himself on
the straw hatch ship in that same Barrel
they used to capture him 500 chapters
before Caribou has no knowledge of
hockey and is not very durable so any
opponent with basic Armament would most
likely beat him in a fight for that
reason I'll Place him in the E tier
before we cover the last and maybe even
the strongest loia user in the series
let's cover revolutionary Army's Chief
of Staff Sabo Sabo obtained the maram
maromi during the tournament in dress
Rosa stealing it from a chest before the
competition even ended Ed him consuming
the fruit and continuing Ace's Legacy
just felt right at first Sabo struggled
to get used to the fruit but just a
little bit later he was already strong
enough to fight against fujit TOA and
Jesus Bess he even ended up defeating
Bess with A's signature firefist attack
although we don't know much about how
exactly Sabo uses this fruit in combat
we know that he can combine the fire of
mam maromi with his Rios again martial
art in order to deal devastating damage
he was also shown capable of uing flames
into the weapons he uses recently in the
story Sabo sneaked into the holy land of
mar joa and met the rulers of the world
U face to face although there was a
bunch of strong enemies attacking him he
showed to be resilient and skilled
enough to escape due to all of this a
solid B tier seems about right for him
and now let's cover by far the most
unique logia user in the series whose
devil fruit does the exact opposite of
what loia should do Marshall D teach
although teach seemed like an ordinary
member of the Whitebeard Pirates it was
all just an act and in reality the only
reason he joined the crew was to find
the yummy yumy noi a legendary loia type
devil fruit that grants the user the
power of Darkness the Whitebeard Pirates
eventually found this fruit and teach
had to kill one of his crew mates in
order to attain it this route is much
different than other loia as it doesn't
allow teach to turn into darkness and
regular physical attacks can still hit
him he even stated that any damage he
takes will actually hurt worse than
normal however yummy yummy no me more
than makes up for these weaknesses as it
literally grants teach some of the most
powerful abilities in the whole show
first of all teach can pull things
towards himself similar to the black
hole and once something has been pulled
in it can be absorbed into the darkness
where it will be trapped until teach
himself decides to release it this is
already pretty insane but there's more
teach also has the ability to nullify
other people's devil fruit Powers simply
by touching them which has to be the
most broken ability in the entire show
in the span of a few short years
Blackbeard has gone from an unknown
pirate to being one of the four Emperors
of the sea and having the second highest
active bounty in the entire world with
his fruit literally being called the
most evil and him being the most evil
man Blackbeard can only be put at the
very top of the list in the S tier but
the crazy thing is that we haven't even
seen Blackbeard fight that much but he
probably has many other abilities and
tricks we don't even know about yet
there's an insane theory about his real
powers and you can click here to watch
it next